Picture this: you are an alien and
you're making your journey across space,
when you come across a planet you've
never seen before, Planet Earth.
A car catches your eye. You want to
understand how it works and bring this
amazing technology back to your home
planet. You don't know how this car
works, so you start removing things one
by one from the car to see what happens.
First, you remove the hood and see that
the car will start, so you know it must
not be involved in starting the car.
Next thing you remove is the wheel and
you see that the car can no longer turn
or move without the wheel, so you know
it must somehow be involved in its
motion.
Finally, you remove the door handle and
the car still functions just fine
without the door handle, so you know
that it is not critical for driving the
car. Each time you remove something,
you get a clue about what it might do.
This is one strategy scientists use to
learn what different genes do. Each
gene is the set of instructions for
making a protein with a specific job,
like the instructions for making a door
handle in our car example.
By completely removing that protein
from an animal or a cell, you can see
what changes and make a guess about
that protein's job.
But how do scientists do this? We don't
actually need to remove the entire gene.
Using molecular tools, we can insert a
line in the genetic instructions that
says 'stop making this protein'.
The functional protein is never made,
and we can now look for clues about
what its job might have been. This
technique is called a gene knockout.